(intriguing orchestral music)
- [Narrator] Over the past few months,
the price of gold has been going haywire.
You can see it on this chart.
As the coronavirus pandemic
took hold in March,
the price crashed, alongside stocks,
and then quickly regained.
Then, a frenzy of investment
drove up the price
to all-time highs.
On August 4th, it shot
past $2,000 a troy ounce
for the first time ever,
before another week of big swings.
This volatility is
drawing both main street
and Wall Street investors
seeking fast gains
and leading some analysts to
call it a modern-day gold rush.
But these big moves call into question
gold's reputation as a safe-haven asset.
- Prices can move at a moment's notice
without fundamental reason more.
More volatility means more
risk, and that means gold
isn't the haven, necessarily,
that some people think it is.
- [Narrator] To you understand
why the price of gold
is so volatile, first
you need to understand
how gold trading works.
Like other precious metals,
the price of gold is
tied to physical assets.
- The physical gold
market involves mining,
refining, travel and sale.
- [Narrator] Gold mining
happens on every continent
except Antarctica.
And the top-producing countries
are China, Russia, and Australia.
This work adds up to about 2,500
to 3000 metric tons of gold each year.
This metal is then smelted and refined
before being turned into bars, coins,
and other products like jewelry.
The gold is then shipped around the world,
often stashed in the cargo
of commercial aircrafts.
Much of it is sent to London.
Mostly hidden beneath
the streets of the city,
the Bank of England's vaults
hold around 400,000 bars of
gold worth over $260 billion.
- The physical trading of gold in London
is done behind closed doors
and in secret by a few banks.
So, these banks work
with the London Bullion Market Association
to set the physical price
of a troy ounce of gold,
and that price determines how
much gold is worth everywhere.
- [Narrator] The gold
stash in London is rivaled
only by the Federal
Reserve Bank of New York,
which holds the world's
largest hoard of physical gold.
In other places around the world,
gold is a common investment as well.
- In a lot of cultures in Asia,
people see gold as something
that's having prestige
and intrinsic value
that can be passed down
from generation to generation.
That can be a big source
of physical demand
for jewelry and bars and coins.
- [Narrator] When individual
investors want to buy in,
they generally have a few options.
They can purchase physical
gold in person from dealers
or on websites like APMEX.
They can bid on thousands
of dollars worth of gold
through eBay.
And they can buy exchange-traded funds
that hold physical metal.
The biggest of these is SPDR gold shares,
which is traded on the
New York Stock Exchange.
But this is just the physical market.
Gold is also traded on
a whole different market
that is tied to commodity futures.
This takes us back to New York,
where gold futures trade
on the COMEX division
of the New York Mercantile Exchange.
Futures are contracts which
lock the price of a commodity
that will change hands at
a specific future date.
A standard futures contract
is tied to 100 ounces of gold
worth over $200,000,
depending on the market.
- The most actively traded
month for gold futures right now
is December because that's
a month people expect
the pandemics issues to
maybe be resolved by,
and it's a month around
the November's presidential election.
A lot of people are very
nervous about the outcome
of that election and
that it might be delayed,
so they're using these
December gold futures
to give themselves options
and protect against market turmoil.
- [Narrator] But gold has slipped lately
after a long run-up,
a reminder that momentum in
this market can change quickly.
Still, this hasn't stopped gold bugs.
And there are a few reasons why people
continue to pile money
into the metal right now.
For a lot of investors,
it started in March,
when mines, refineries and airlines
shut down across the world,
upending the system usually used
to move gold across the
Atlantic and stabilize prices.
But when the pandemic hit,
investors feared there wouldn't be a way
to physically move gold
between the markets.
This caused physical
gold purchases to soar,
leading to a severe shortage
that drove up the price of futures.
But there are other reasons too.
- There are a lot of people
who are very bullish on gold
and think it's an alternative currency
that provides a hedge against inflation
and is very attractive when
interest rates are low.
Many bulls are piling into the sector
because they think the Federal Reserve
and other central banks
are eroding the value of paper money
by pumping a ton of cash into
the global financial system
to support the economy.
- [Narrator] The increased activity
is contributing to momentum trading,
driving a frenzy for
gold, similar to stocks.
But if inflation doesn't materialize,
the momentum that gold
is seeing could unravel.
- Analysts say the current
trading environment
is extremely risky.
People say all of the economic
and political instability
could last for a lot longer than we think.
At the same time, if the economic recovery
goes better than expected,
if there's a coronavirus vaccine
more quickly than we think,
gold could have some issues.
- [Narrator] This means
that gold could face
more volatility moving forward.
(light orchestral music)